Watch the silver eye on top of the are
just watch
Every time it swings
Let's pretend we're unraveling a piece of string
little by little
Let's pretend that piece of string is time
Unraveling minute by minute
Second by second
going backwards
time
slipping away
Everything around you
this house
my voice
your mother
all these things
Are getting further away
We're going back through your life
Back to when you started school when?
You first learned to walk
When you were just a baby
Back to the day you were born
Back to the time before this model
I'm no longer speaking to miles
I'm speaking to the person who has taken residence inside his body
He came uninvited
Tell me if you can hear my voice
Miles
Miles what's wrong?
Mommy I'm scared
Come here, baby